welcome to this video I'm doing round
one of the candidates in London and well
I wasn't so sure should be doing a full
coverage because it's really time
consuming but I'll do a daily video it
probably won't be so long as the wijk
aan zee videos which really got out of
hand at some point like 80 minutes or
something for one video so I'll try to
keep it a little bit shorter this time
and most of the time will I will
concentrate on just one game however in
the first round and gives you a brief
overview of all the games and you'll
understand soon why this is possible
let's have a brief look aronian against
cousin obviously two tournament
favourites cards and being the absolute
top favorite of course and he placed the
bogo indian if you followed my channel
recently you might have seen a video
where I talked about my book project i'm
writing a book which features this
opening so I was kind of curious what
what's happened Bishop d2 and now the
capture this is an old favorite of fun
lasagnes the Swedish top Grand Master of
the 70s and 80s mostly he is
semi-retired now being almost 6 60 years
old I think so in its late late 50s 60s
so this capture it's a very very solid
opening Queen d2 d5 so Carson um chooses
a very very solid set up no Kings Indian
know let's say been only on some opening
where you can easily get the blown of
the board just a no-nonsense equalizing
line and very surprisingly for me aronia
didn't have anything to show against
this some
it is actually a very well known that
the only way to combat this is with
fianchetto and normally it is happening
now this g3 move you maybe can also
think about covering c4 with was smooth
like this or Quincy too but in general
you need to fianchetto in this position
and this would actually lead to position
that Carlton has played before he am in
fact had played Bishop before a couple
of times in this position which is
similar here g3 is already a plate for
white and team had this numerous times
he beat kram leg for instance with black
in this line so I'm really a surprise
that aronian didn't have anything
against this and played Knight c3 here
and III plate is rather quickly even I
didn't check this before so but i'm
really i'm wondering if this is a
preparation or whatever because it's
simply equalizing for black and and in
very very simple fashion queen e seven
books he won rookie eight and now with
this some kind of setup white basically
needs to move the Queen again to cannot
stay on the default so for the Queen
move and here the normal way to equalize
this position I don't think there's more
than one way is to simply capture on c4
and play c5 further intending this kind
of setup and this is also basically dead
I mean it's on this level of almost sure
draw cards are played it slightly
differently but also very logical first
developing a couple of pieces and now
there should be two yeah I mean even
Here I am aronian could have maybe try
to to play this kind of exchange
variation on d5 the cards but structure
probably am
cards and goes for see five or something
else not see six but I mean II played
this and really look at this takes c5
here whatever b5 so this is so easy to
play and they both playing quickly I
mean it's simply a nothing game now
exchanged on c5 reform and a for when
this kills off the hook you inside Queen
takes before and further exchanges yeah
now we are in a kind of position where
even let's say any normal club player I
can try to draw against Magnus yeah we
have all kinds of exchanges this is the
only fun thing about this draw greeting
in a completely symmetrical position um
yeah very disappointing game um but
there are things the first round
obviously you don't want to start with a
loss this is clear and maybe for some
reason aronian didn't really have
anything prepared i don't know i mean
this cannot be the preparation you can
easily see that this is just nothing and
on move 10 and he played this in about
10 minutes he played this very quickly
and it's simply nothing maybe he also
was content with the draw you never know
don't have any inside information on the
other situation so maybe you didn't
sleep the whole night because you were
sick or something and then you're glad
that you have got this sort of nothing
game and can try to recover for the next
day it's just I'm just saying there are
things that you that we have no
information about so sometimes those
kind of bleak games can be explained
with um yeah very human circumstances
um yeah well for the spectator nothing
game we also had Sevilla playing kramnik
adhere the opening was the most
interviewing fine kramnik played the
Queens gambit declined with with this 9
f 66 move water usually it's it's a
given that black is playing the new Zoey
and chronic of course is a longtime
Nivens o specialist but he PA played d 5
which is very uncommon at the top level
basically no one allows this because of
the classical exchange variation
discards with structure which is some
slight advantage for white it's very
difficult for like two completely
equalize that there are ways where you
can get very close to equality but it's
still a slight pool no one really likes
to defend it on at the top level but
chronic had an entirely different idea
on takes d5 here he just took with the
night and this is very rare at this at
this stage but not necessarily bad I had
a look at this quite a while ago I
didn't really find something great for
white I'm Swilley play d4 takes takes c5
and this can now if white would play
Knight f3 can now transpose to the
so-called semi talaash or improved
tirage um this is normally reached in a
different order of course look at this
here d 593 c5 it takes takes this is the
so-called improved towers or semi garage
where black has captured with a knight
on d5 and in the game we look at this
Knight f3 now would actually transpose
after a four and the other position and
captures it usually continues in this
fashion like giving a check
yeah counseling and now black guy goes
to you seven often with the queen bee
six we should be 797 yeah Queenie seven
is not to not play it all the time it is
just the possibility but this is a very
solid position for black and can be
recommended to play I'm so now I ever
played a 3 which is quite often given as
a sort of argument against this specific
move water because now if you look at
this after the exchange there's simply
no check on before and this check is
really helpful for Blackie he likes to
get rid of one pair of minor pieces um
here however chrome Nicki I'm played an
interesting idea played 85 and this is
some quite curious if white now takes
which is bad i think this some leads to
a very open position where black has no
problems to activate his bishops and I
don't see why I'm this shouldn't be
about equal yes we looked at NIDA three
and we got a queen trade early on so
chrome netgear as as it is quite often
has some exchange queens early this
position is somewhere around slightly
better for white and and equal and I've
got a couple of rather normal-looking
moves night transferred here and Bishop
to d7 I think here white should
seriously consider to play a four but
swidler was playing it very very very
safe Ashley first played this would be
one
Andrew Kelsey one here instead of Roxy
one he had had alternatives one possible
idea was for example look to d1 or
moving the king and now sort of
prophylactic fashion what he did this
look to see one was answered by this
check and now you need to go to f3 who
don't want to retreat so f3 and now this
move and what is why it's supposed to do
now the rookie is hanging and it cannot
move because of false in this Bishop so
Bishop c2 was the only movement now
kramnik just dropped it all the way back
and introduced this night c4 idea 94
really would be an ugly moved to to face
white with them let's say I move like a
form just for for example then 94 and 95
s as possible and maybe he just wants to
take also it's just just not good to
allow this so this is why Swilley played
back to be three be sure d3 and now we
got the perpetual or repetition of moves
perpetual as wrong word and draw a grid
but at this point I think there's not
much point in doing something else I
think rambling also was satisfied he
could theoretically here think about
here think about some other move but
what better move is there then we should
be three wideouts on my tongue continue
with with some moves g45 whatever
blankets the UCM they need to need to
force the draw like a not play forward
yeah so this was filled a chronic pretty
quick draw also and now let's have a
look at Yvonne Chaka against greece
shock here we got very popular opening
nowadays
no bling where Grisha played the main
line the open Catalan dumb PF this this
variation now now white can play a
multitude of moves Bishop f4 Bishop g5
Bishop d to the most them testing is
maybe Bishop to detune but it's not not
the only move as mentioned eventual
plays Bishop g5 now 97 and he took on f6
92 this is what is the idea black the
white exchanges this Bishop early and
tries to quickly get this night to
control c5f were white and managers to
stop the sea porn from moving and keeps
the ball on c7 or c6 then why did enjoy
is a very distinct advantage because you
simply pressurize the spawn like this
controlling the square um black really
needs to do something concrete you
cannot just stay and hope that it's all
not so bad one way here and this is
actually how I play myself as black is
the move c5 with the idea after d take
c5 to play night to you for and get this
back this is a very clear equalizer in
my opinion okay white can try various
things but it's it's very very dry um
this is the the tried-and-tested
mainline still um even shook spend lots
of time and degree should also so it's a
hard to tell what why they took so long
for all this this is has been played
like
dozens of times some some exchanges here
the traditional okay this is normal and
Queen am also a good move this intense
to protect the bishop and puts pressure
on this long diagonal here the normal
mouthless actually queen to deform and
super Knight f6 this has been played
quite a number of times with them not
surprisingly the normal result being a
draw it is very Jewish those two lines C
and D file open and mostly this leads to
further exchanges even shock even try it
a little bit of something by moving the
bishop away so that bishops are not
exchanged against each other but it's
it's not dangerous we shook simply took
here had initiated further exchanges and
yeah yeah what um what to say it's
simply nothing happening yeah here black
has at least a little threat now it's a
big threat even if white needs to react
plate b3 simply preventing the night
coming to see form and now i'm just back
95 here white could take on d5 and this
would actually need to the position we
get in the game where the deep bone is
exchanged here and at first you might
think this is four against three and two
against one but isn't a 5a for a
possible quick pass porn so black is
even better omnia this term is something
that white needs to take care of you
needs to get to play quickly to secure
draw and this is what he's doing giving
you this check
and now f5 this is an important move
opening up the King position if you now
would take him as black then there's
Quincy eight came here and queen takes
and yahwah you've got this threat with
the perpetual coming for example like
this here oops and end it simply simply
dead white needs to force a draw cannot
play on with the to pass porn spoof of
black on the queenside in the game it
was a somewhat similar yeah here whiter
of course cannot exchange on his exes
would you lose but then after this
there's simply not much happening the
King's here is much too exposed black am
not in any way try to use his his free
porns yes hi spawns so he went for the
Queen exchange and this King opponent
game is is simply dead white can play f3
and g4 enter this happens here adhere
draw was agreed white can simply play g4
let's play deform clients for example
take stakes be form
yeah something like this and now I'm
yeah well it really doesn't matter h5
it's just dead yeah quite quite similar
it's not a symmetrical but close to this
both sides cannot play the the polar
cannot take the bonus then the other one
would promote like a black in this
position cannot take because what will
get a new queen so I'm a dead drawn on a
bone endgame yeah this leaves one game
this is girl found a job of default
plate as usual form galfond and her job
of plate b6 which is a slight surprise
he played this move on when he was just
breaking through the on to the top
grandma's tournaments when he played
also the French defense to beat Kasparov
in 2003 it's it i think it was from a
very dodgy position but he won the game
against the great world champion um yeah
buddy six he hasn't played for a really
long time the job of is more known of
course for his Kings Indian which here
very often won against top opposition
but something else here the idea
obviously is this Gavin doesn't play you
for so sorry knew that he would get this
on the board this check here often known
as the carers variation it is some
similar of course to the bogo engine
that we saw before in cars this game and
in fact after 92 which is a bit more
ambitious than Bishop e2 we just posed
to the logo castles a 3 Bishop e7 e four
so we have a position where black has
lost a move with Bishop to b4 and then
back but in the meantime white has
played the most Bishop Knight to d2
blocking the bishop and the move a 3 a 3
often is useful
as before and yeah controls the square
and before but the night on d 2 is
sometimes a really miserable piece and
this makes all this playable for black
the normal and most confrontational
moves now is d5 this is a very sharp in
fact after a 597 Bishop d3 and c5 we
reach a position which is very typical
in a way for the French but this is the
a typical move the pawn on c4 which
initiates this huge tension in the
center so I'm a very interesting and
complicated position but a job of plate
something else he played the move on d 6
which is very rare in this position and
it's quite funny it was my intention to
recommend this move in my book and now I
just play it with it's not new it has
been played by some grant masters but
still only in a handful of games and
Bishop e2 and now 97 here in fact I had
some some other idea was c5 but ok it's
it's interesting here as well before and
II five this was where Joe's idea he
lost them throw the tempo here with that
the two poor moves compared to the old
Indian defense and black is basically
playing the old Indian with two moves
down he took two moves with Bishop
before Andy seven and six and then he
five is also two moves but what are
those two moves before a three and
slightly a Miss position of night on on
misplaced dine on tea too so this is
interesting two black two to play it is
still not very exciting admittedly as
mentioned when I will suggest this move
and my book it
will be a somewhat different with c5 is
black okay but how did continue Bishop
b2 a five castles and now it takes on d4
and normal improvement rookie head
bishop f8 so that the night and the rook
initiator some some player against you
for the problem for white ear really is
that this night is simply on a bed
square it doesn't influence the center
so much it's just much better on c3 or
on some other position maybe even on g3
it would be better well it's not great
on g3 as well yeah the night somebody
doesn't belong here we also see after a
couple of moves c6 that blacks idea with
g65 it's very hard to prevent now as the
night it's not controlling this square
white in fact a place that reflect the
move Bishop f1 getting the bishop out of
the e-file so that you can actually take
on d5 and our job of really plays defy
he doesn't want to wait and delay the
break this is the simplest move
attacking me for so in this fashion and
also attacking before and yeah after
takes on d5 black of course doesn't take
here this after c5 would lead to a very
very good position for white with two
pawns against one so you have potential
to get a passport and of course White
has a big blockade on deform so this
would be really a terrible decision you
played however Bishop takes before and
this is just simple and good now this d5
pawn is attacked and white cannot
continue without taking so he took on c6
and now it's almost a complete symmetry
why there's only slightly better
developed but it's not
a tangible advantage I continued just
showing the rest of the moves the only
thing that black needs to do is to get
in c5 at some point exchange the bishop
this happens a couple of moves later
yeah you could argue that white has a
very microscopic advantage because this
is somewhat bad this bishop but it's
just not too much to to win a game a
couple oops mm-hmm got a couple of how
do I even change this now this oh it's
working hit the wrong button here yeah
well this was the most exciting moment
of the video probably okay so it saw
further exchanges and here even the sea
points were put off the board and now a
jog read so we had four quick draws in
the first round and not two weeks I
exciting a chance obviously this is why
I did all four games just give you a
brief impression that was simply not
much happening today um yeah I think the
one reason is certainly that you don't
want to start with a loss into such
tournament this is understandable um the
the favorites here Kramnik and cousin
had black um certainly a draw is not too
bad with the black pieces so they didn't
do anything fancy aronian I think
disappointed a bit with his very um yeah
unambitious way to combat this this
opening um k even shocked with this
Catalan with Bishop g5 always also I
wanted to play it too safe it seems so
nobody wanted to lose and this mindset
is some very often
yeah just just leading to draw at this
level if you don't want to lose and play
it very safe with white I'm very often
it will it will be a draw um but okay
this tournament really sees um yeah
really it's very easy to understand only
first place counts second place or third
place or 888 place or whatever besides
some some rating points it's no no
difference so um there certainly will be
decisive games and interesting chess but
it didn't happen today it simply need
some some decisive games to to get to
get rolling maybe I'm even tomorrow will
we see something like that yeah make
sure to keep tuned for further coverage
I'm pretty sure that the games will get
more interesting yeah thanks for
watching I'll be back tomorrow cheers